[Music]  why would you need to do this to track  people when almost everybody is carrying  something around  that provides a wealth of information  about us including our location meaning  our mobile phones  in addition to that most people's credit  cards debit cards  now also have chips on them which  if you wanted to have it do dual uh  do the dual roll of also tracking people  you could do it that way why would the  government need to microchip people  via an optional vaccine when everybody's  already carrying around a phone and most  people carry  are carrying around a debit or a credit  card so it doesn't even pass the sniff  test but  um the the this is really it has spread  like a mind virus